تلتهب المحاور عشرات الاشتباكات القتاليه
خلال ساعات تلك الساعات الافضل بحسب
الاوكرانيين الى تحقيقهم عمليه تقدم جديده
في اقليم دومباس بشرقي البلاد ذكر مثلا
شان محوري ضخمه
يؤكد الجيش الاوكراني فضلا عن ذلك تصديه
لمحاوله هجوميه روسيه على
محوريكا كما يواصل عمليه التمشيط حول بلده
كليشييفكا التي اعاد السيطره عليها قبل
اسبوع من زاويه النظر الاوكرانيه ستتراء
لك انجازات الهجوم المضاد الذي قيل بشانه
الكثير
حتى على مستوى الدفاع ستتبدى انجازات من
نوع اخر
لعل من ذلك حديث الجيش الاوكراني عن تصديه
لعشرات الغارات الجويه والهجمات
بالمقذوفات الصاروخيه التي تستهدف في
الغالب موانئ اوديسا وصوامع تخزين الحبوب
لكن للروس ايضا زاويه ينظرون من خلالها
لمجريات الميدان
ما يسمونها عملياتهم العسكريه في اوكرانيا
لا يعوقها كما يقولون كل المدد العسكري
الذي يتلقاه الطرف الاخر من الغرب
في احدث هجماته استهدف الجيش الروسي مركز
تحكم عسكري في
شرق اوكرانيا
اما هناك جنوبا فهدف هذه المره مستودع
ذخيره تابع للقوات الاوكرانيه في بلده
بمقاطعه خرسون غير ان تاثيرات استمرار
الهجمه الاوكرانيه لا سيما بالطائرات
المسيره امر يصعب على موسكو مداراته هذا
جسر القرم الاستراتيجي الذي تعرض لهجمات
اوكرانيه متكرره خلال الشهور الماضيه
ربما كانت تجدد الهجمات هو ما حمل روسيا
مجددا على تعليق حركه المرور على الجسر
قبل ان تستانفها في وقت لاحق الهجوم
الاخير على مقر اسطول البحر الاسود الروسي
في سيفا ستوبل هو واحد من الهجمات التي
تعدوها كييف نوعيه يخرج قائد الاسطول
فيكتور الذي قال الاوكرانيون انه قتل في
الهجوم ليؤكد ان مهام اسطوله تنفذ بنجاح
كما حددتها القياده
اللافت للنظر اكثر ان تخرج موسكو الان
لتوجه اصابع الاتهام الى كل من لندن
وواشنطان
المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا
زخارفا قالت ان كيا هاجمت الجمعه الماضيه
مقر الاسطول الروسي في سيفا ستوبل
بالتنسيق مع من سمته باختصاصيين امريكيين
وبريطانيين
اتهام اخر باثر رجعي تقول موسكو ان واشنطن
ضالعتان بشكل او باخر في تفجير انابيب
ستريم قبل نحو عام خط نورت ستريم كما نعلم
يعتبر من اهم المنشات المزوده للطاقه وكان
يمد العديد من الدول الاوروبيه بالغاز